Olá meus queridos minhas queridas sejam
muito bem-vindos a mais uma live Boa
noite Carlos
ketman por favor vão entrando me dizendo
se o áudio está legal se vocês me ouvem
bem vamos discutir alguns artigos hoje e
em seguida responder à dúvidas hoje tem
pouca dúvida talvez porque amanhã é
feriado
né Vamos esperar o pessoal entrar também
só temos o Carlos qu ao vivo hoje ou tem
mais
gente deixa eu tirar o barulhinho do
WhatsApp bem vamos lá primeir artig
queria conversar com vocês é um artigo
de revisão grande que eu fiz um resumo
para apresentar Como é que está a visão
da ciência Ortodoxa em relação à
vitamina D Boa noite
Eliseu Então vamos
desvendar os mistérios da vitamina D ou
hormônio D como vocês sabem é mais muito
mais hormônio que a
vitamina então do artigo que é um artigo
de revisão grande é consensus Statement
on vitam D stat assessment and
supplementation né Wise w and House ele
foi publicado numa revista pro
especialistas renomados da
área então vamos falar um pouco sobre a
jornada da vitamina D no nosso organismo
de onde vem a vitamina D ou hormônio D
ela pode ser obtida de duas maneiras
pela síntese na pele através da
exposição à luz solar especialmente a
ultravioleta B que estimula a pele a
produzir a partir do colesterol e pela
ingestão de alimentos como peixes
gordurosos gema de ovos e alimentos
fortificados Lógico que essa segunda via
pela alimentação é muito menos relevante
e a vitamina D ela ativada em duas
etapas a vitamina D obtida pela dieta ou
sintetizada na pele ela é inativa então
para ela se tornar ativa e exercer suas
funções ela passa por duas hidroxilações
a primeira hidroxilação acontece no
fígado e trans forma ela em 25 hidróxi
vitamina D A segunda hidroxilação
acontece nos INSS resultando na forma
1,25 de hidro vitamina D na verdade 1,25
de hidróxi vitamina
D que é o calcitriol né Então a primeira
ativação forma o calcidiol que é o 25
hidróxi e a segunda ativação forma o
calcitriol calcidiol e calol o
calcitriol também é conhecido como 1,25
de Ox vitamina
D então todo esse processo de ativação é
orquestrado com várias enzimas e
proteínas como é o caso da enzima
cip 2 R1 que é responsável pela primeira
hidroxilação e a cip 27 B1 que realiza a
segunda
hidroxilação então mutações essas
enzimas podem levar a doenças como o
caso raquitismo né que hoje é muito raro
mas que ainda existe raquitismo é aquela
doença
que a criança fica uma estatura muito
baixa com deformidade óssea por falta de
vitamina D
ativada Boa noite Miriam Pessoal vocês
me escutam bem não tive feedback do
áudio
ainda então a vitamina D como vocês
sabem ela tem uma ação
multifacetada ela é muito além dos Ossos
a vitamina D ela atua como hormônio Liga
seu receptor de vitamina D chamado vdr
né na sigla em inglês vitamin D receptor
e esse receptor está presente
virtualmente todas as células no nosso
corpo é por isso que a vitamina D
influencia não só a saúde óssea mas
também diversos outros processos
fisiológicos então em relação à absorção
de cálcio que é a função clássica da
vitamina D que é o quê promover a
absorção de cálcio no nosso intestino
isso é essencial para a mineralização
óssea e a prevenção de de doenças como
raquitismo e
osteoporose mas tem vários efeitos
também Extra ósseos a vitamina D Atua em
vários sistemas vou falar aqui dos
principais atua no sistema imunológico
modulando a resposta inflamatória e a
defesa contra infecções então estudos
sugerem que ela pode ter um papel na
prevenção de doenças autoimunes como
esclerose múltipla nós sabemos muito bem
né o protocolo Dr
Coimbra do tor cícer Galo imbra para
esclerose múltipla é conhecida
internacionalmente e tem bons resultados
também pode ser utilizado para tritom
mató entre outras doenças
autoimunes Boa Noite Marta Obrigado
Miriam pelo feedback do áudio e também a
vitamina D atua na saúde cardiovascular
E na saúde metabólica evidências
recentes indicam que a vitamina D pode
tá relacionada à saúde cardiovascular
metabólica com potencial impacto na
prevenção de diabetes tipo dois Então
melhora a sensibilidade a insulina
também vai atuar na prevenção da pressão
alta hipertensão arterial e doenças
cardiovasculares Então existe vários
marcadores que a gente pode acompanhar
para ver o estatus de vitamina D O mais
conhecido é o 25 hidroxi vitamina D que
é o que eu peço na
rotina essa dosagem da 25 hidroxi o
principal indicador de status de
vitamina D no organismo existe uma
questão aí de desafio na dosagem um
problema de padronização nos métodos de
dosagem na definição dos níveis ideais
de vitamina d25
hidró que ainda são temas de debate Na
Comunidade científica O que torna
interpretação dos resultados um pouco
complexa Então existe uma questão
questionamento se devemos fazer rastreio
populacional ou se só devemos medir em
casos individualizados então isso aí não
é um caso ainda definido na literatura
devido às controvérsias e aos custos o
rastreio da vitamina D da deficiência da
vitamina D na população geral geralmente
não é recomendado Apesar de que todos
meus pacientes eu faço sim a dosagem é
mais indicada para indivíduos com
fatores de risco no caso esse aqui é
opinião do artigo pessoal depois a gente
pode até discutir se tá correta ou não
mas ele indica que só deve medir pessoas
com risco como com caso idosos gestantes
pessoas com pele mais escura que absorve
menor absorve menos obesos e portadores
de doenças
crônicas nós sabemos que a deficiência
de vitamina D é um problema de saúde
pública isso o artigo reconhece a
deficiência grave de vitamina D pode
levar ao raquitismo nas crianças como eu
falei é baixa estatura e deformidades
ósseas e a osteomalácia em adultos né
que é o osso fraco que pode causar dor e
fraqueza
muscular também em adultos mais de idade
a deficiência de vitamina D aumenta o
risco de osteoporose doença que
fragiliza os óssos e aumenta o risco de
fraturas e as implicações Extra ósseas a
deficiência de vitamina D tem sido
associada a um risco aumentado de
doenças autoimunes diabetes tipo do
doenças cardiovasculares infecções
respiratórias alguns tipos de câncer até
mesmo covid-19 mais estudos são
necessários para confirmar essas
associações e determinar papel da
suplementação na prevenção dessas
doenças Então como é que devemos
suplementar a vitamina D a opção
preferencial pelo col
calciferol que seria a vitamina
D3 é a forma mais comum mais segura de
tratamento da deficiência
está amplamente disponível é eficaz na
elevação dos níveis isso aí ninguém
discute a dose ideal é que é muito
discutida ela vai variar de acordo com a
idade peso etnia latitude condições
clínicas e níveis iniciais de 25 hidró
vitamina D no organismo do indivíduo
Ok qual que seria a frequência de
administração a dose de Á é considerada
mais fisiológica mas esquemas de dosagem
semanais e mensais são aceitáveis com
doses obviamente maiores e podem ser
utilizados para melhorar desão caso a
pessoa esqueça de tomar todos os dias e
a administração intramuscular né a via
parenteral né Nesse artigo específico
ele não recomenda como forma principal
mas em casos que é comprovado uma
absorção intestinal poderia ser indicada
a injeção intramuscular via parental de
vitamina D O calcifediol
é uma outra forma de vitamina D
calcifediol
ele pode ser utilizado em alguns casos
tá específicos porque ele é mais
facilmente absorvido pode ser útil em
caso de obesidade ou malabsorção e a
formativa o calcitriol que também existe
no mercado é utilizado em situações
específicas como doenças renais e
hipoparatiroidismo
porque se você usar vitamina D normal né
que calcidiol você pode piorar esseo
para tiroidismo no
caso segurança e acompanhamento
prudência sempre é fundamental existe um
risco de
toxicidade a suplementação da vitamina D
raramente vai acontecer se a pessoa
tiver níveis aí um pouco acima de 100 no
sangue mas eu não recomendo que ninguém
a tenha vitamina D acima de se atenta
por questõ de segurança porque se a
pessoa tiver maus hábitos es tiver
desidratada e tiver ingerindo muito
cálcio se ela tiver com a vitamina D no
sangue por volta de 100 ela pode ser ter
sinais de
intoxicação e essa intoxicação pode
levar hipercalcemia que é o excesso de
cálcio no sangue e outras complicações
como calcificação de tecidos moles
calcificação dos rins cálculos urinários
calcificação do pericárdio e também de
juntas
acompanhar os níveis de vitamina D
durante o tratamento é importante
obviamente tá especialmente pacientes
que tenha uma absorção obesidade que
esteja utilizando medicamentos que
interferem na metabolismo na vitamina D
certo então conclusão a vitamina D
desempenha um papel crucial na saúde mas
existem muitas questões ainda serem
exploradas a avaliação do estus de
vitamina D e a suplementação devem ser
individualizados levando em consideração
as necessidades cada pessoa óbvio né
pessoal é preciso estar atento aos
fatores de risco de deficiência como é
ele comentou aqui gestantes idosos
pessoas que pele mais escura e lógico
conversar com o seu médico
para discutir a melhor forma de garantir
níveis adequados de vitamina
D Então vamos responder aqui alguns
comentários já que estão aparecendo aqui
o eliz tá
comentando somos um país com sol em
abundancia porém as pessoas ficam em
ambientes fechados e usam produtor solar
sim é
verdade por isso que tem deficiência
vitamina D no Brasil no Canadá é comum
as pessoas a pessoa negra adoecer e
voltar pro seu país de origem devido ao
Pouco sol que tem lá adoecer Sim eles eu
voltar pro país de origem nunca vi dados
a respeito mas talvez você tenha visto
aí de alguma fonte
pessoa negra demora muito tempo muito
mais tempo para abver vitamina D isso
exatamente bem vamos pro próximo
artigo bem esse artigo ele discute a
questão da gordura saturada né uma
informação bem interessante que eu
queria dividir com vocês sobre a matriz
alimentar então vocês sabiam que não é
só a quantidade mas o tipo de gordura
saturada que você consome que pode ter
Impacto afetar a tua saúde
cardiovascular Então é isso que nós
vamos explorar nesse tema explorando uma
pesquisa inovadora que revela verdades
surpreendentes sobre o consumo diário de
iogurte integral
versus iogurte de baixa gordura com
manteiga então a ideia aqui seria
comparar duas situações que tem uma
quantidade equivalente de gordura
saturada então iogurtes integral que tem
gordura saturada iogurte de baixa
gordura mas associando com manteiga A
ideia é comparar assim será que manteiga
Dá no mesmo de que usar iogurte integral
em termos de gordura em termos de
gordura saturada Vamos ver isso aqui ess
artigo eu achei bem interessante posso
não concordar com tudo que tem aqui mas
eu achei interessante
então pode ser surpreendente saber que
mesmo com a mesma quantidade de gordura
derivada do leite esses dois alimentos a
manteiga e o iogurte integral sem
retirar gordura impactam de maneira
muito diferente na saúde do coração
especialmente No que diz respeito às
proteínas que carregam o colesterol as
apolipoproteínas
que estão intimamente ligadas ao
desenvolvimento de doenças
cardiovasculares
Então vamos abordar aente a fascinante
ciência por trás dos efeitos dos
diversos tipos de gorduras no nosso coro
então não perca esse episódio onde vamos
revelar essas
informações bem sabemos que a conexão
entre as gorduras saturadas e as doenças
cardiovasculares não é se trata de um
tema novo mas a maneira pela qual
diferentes tipos de elementos cicos em
gordura saturada afetam o corpo camente
é um campo de constante estudo novamente
Pessoal esse artigo que nós estamos
analisando é um artigo que enxerga pelo
lado convencional que a gordura saturada
faz mal pro coração Ok então vamos ver
essa perspectiva do artigo depois a pode
discutir mas acho que o ponto principal
não é nem se gordura saturada faz bem ou
mal mas o tipo de Matriz da gordura isso
que eu acho interessante Nesse artigo
aqui então a pesquisa a qual nós nos os
hoje vai destacar especificamente o
papel do iogurte e da manteiga em
parâmetros lipídicos e proteínas
envolvidas nos processos de
aterosclerose então na avaliação atual
30 participantes saudáveis ingeriram o
iogurte de baixa gordura acrescido de
manteiga e iogurte integral no outro
grupo tá ambos Contendo a mesma
quantidade de gordura Total Láctea então
o resultado mostrou que embora o consumo
de iogurte inteiro
integral não alterasse de maneira
significativa os níveis de apoproteína b
a adição de manteiga resultou em um
aumento de 14 MG por dcil dessa ap
lipoproteína B crucialmente ligada né ao
desenvolvimento de doença cardiovascular
dado seu papel nas lipoproteínas
aterogênicas n Então vamos a um exemplo
prático Imagine que você vocês consomem
regularmente uma porção de iogurte com
pedaço de fruta no café da manhã alterar
de iogurte integral para iogurte de
baixa gordura com adicional de Manteiga
no pão Pode parecer uma escolha
insignificante mas esse estudo ele
sugere que essa simples mudança poderia
aumentar um biomarcador associado ao
risco de doença
cardiovascular então quando falamos em
avaliar os riscos para doença no coração
é importante entender
as medidas utilizadas para essas
avaliações então estamos falando de LDL
colesterol Colesterol não HDL e apol
proteína B são agentes que ajudam a
entender o potencial de atter esclerose
e o risco de doença
cardiovascular tanto o LDL colesterol
quanto o colesterol não HDL né que é o
vldl e o idl eles são utilizados como
indicadores de risco para doenças
cardiovasculares no entanto panto o
nível de ap lipoproteína B é a métrica
mais precisa desses três porque ele mede
diretamente o número de lipoproteínas
contendo a pobo proteína B em vez de
estimar Com base no conteúdo de
colesterol que pode variar Então o jeito
mais preciso sem ser aquela análise
profunda das partículas de colesterol
que analisa o número de partículas o
tamanho de partículas é avaliação do apo
lipoproteína b a relação dela com apo
lipoproteína A então AP o A tá no HDL
colesterol e a pro B tá no quilomicron
no LDL no idl e no vldl então todas as
partículas que são aterogênicas tem a
apo b e o HDL colesterol tem a apo a Tá
bom eu sei que pode ser meio complicado
isso mas se vocês não entenderem eu
posso tentar explicar de uma outra
maneira então Imagine que o LDL
colesterol funciona como porteiro que
abre a porta para o colesterol entrar
nas suas artérias portanto níveis Altos
de LDL e colesterol e colesterol não HDL
sugere que esse porteiro está
ativo agora oe apolipoproteína B é
representativo do número total de
porteiros circulando o seu sistema se o
número de apolipoproteína B aumenta mais
porteiros estão potencialmente
disponíveis para permitir essa passagem
aumentando o risco de doença pessoal
novamente Isso aqui é uma visão do
artigo que não necessariamente a minha
visão Ok mas podemos discutir isso a
adiante Então vamos falar sobre a matriz
alimentar que eu mais interessa Nesse
artigo
aqui a matriz alimentar ou seja como os
nutrientes interagem como os nutrientes
interagem e são estruturados nos
alimentos que comemos é determinante na
maneira como essas gorduras influenciam
nosso corpo não é apenas a quantidade de
gordura saturada mas como ela é
apresentada no contexto dos alimentos
Então vamos entender melhor isso aqui a
manteiga tem um perfil de Matriz
alimentar que aumenta o LDL colesterol
em comparação com outros produtos
láctos Diferentemente de outros produtos
laticíneos a manteiga tem um conteúdo
muito baixo de membrana de glóbulo de
gordura do leite na sigla inglês
mfgm mfgm então eu não conhecia isso
aqui aprendi isso agora então tá
ele tem então
repetindo manteiga tem um conteúdo muito
baixo de membrana de glô de gordura do
leite então esse tal de mfgm parece ter
um papel protetor contra a elevação dos
lipídios sanguíneos tá então tem uma
diferença entre o queijo e a manteiga
apesar de ter mesma quantidade
proporcional de
gordura o primeiro
queijo influencia menos negativamente o
perfil lipídico por quê porque tem umas
propriedades dessa tal Matriz alimentar
incluindo que tem mais esse mfgm Então
esse mfgm
protege a pessoa Teoricamente da gordura
saturada Então como a manteiga não tem
fgm a gordura da manteiga impacta mais o
apolipo proteína B do que a gordura do
do queijo que tem esse mfgm tá não sei
se ficou Claro para vocês mas é tal da
mfgm que tá rica no queijo que protege a
pessoa do da gordura
saturada então alguns produtos láctos
como iogurte o queijo são fermentados
Olha só o poder da fermentação O que
significa que possuem culturas de
bactérias que podem ter efeitos
benéficos que vão além das propriedades
das gorduras que contém então devido a
esse conteúdo probiótico esses produtos
podem influenciar positivamente a
microbiota intestinal que por sua vez
pode modificar a forma como o nosso
corpo metaboliza e utiliza as gorduras o
consumo regular de iogurte que é um
produto fermentado pode contribuir não
só para saúde digestória mas também para
o melhor perfil lipídico e
consequentemente para uma redução no
risco de doenças C
vasculares tá então assim pessoal eu fiz
lá em Ribeiro eu fiz a posse e eu
aprendi lá que gordura saturada não é
vilão mas aqui eu tô apresentando para
vocês uma visão diferente então a gente
tem que ter a cabeça aberta para ver
mais de uma visão e analisar e chegar a
nossas próprias conclusões Eu
particularmente
não demoniza a gordura saturada por
exemplo eu oriento a usar óleo de coco
eu oriento a usar óleo de abacate que
são gorduras saturadas Eu só não gosto
muito da gordura do leite eu não
recomendo muito mas a manteiga é
Manteiga clarificada eu
recomendo aqui mais a a medicina
Ortodoxa ainda coloca aura saturada com
grande vilão e esse artigo aqui tá
apresentando situação que existe uma
diferença mesmo você pega uma quantidade
de queijo ou iogurte de manteiga
manteiga por não ter essa proteína
protetora que eu falei ele acaba sendo
mais prejudicial do que o iogurte e do
que o queijo ok
bem Vamos
então responder as dúvidas deixa eu ver
os comentários ao vivo
aqui miram na prática eu não vejo
problema nenhum de absorção na vitamina
D contanto que ela
seja consumida com gordura saudável Tá
mas a
sublingual sublingual bem absorvida sim
tá
e a o acompanhamento da vitamina K2 é
importante quando você tá ingerindo
10.000 ou mais de vitamina D por
dia exatamente que o Elisão tá falando
aqui bem Vamos às
dúvidas deixa eu apresentar a tela para
vocês
aqui SL dizer share
screen vamos lá Pergunta da Marilda no
caso PSA Total acima de quatro relação
entre PSA livre e PSA Total deverá ser
que percentual para descartar a
possibilidade de ca bem descartar nunca
vai descartar tá o que a gente usa é
abaixo de 20% você pega o PSA livre e
divide pelo total se o número der abaixo
de 0,20 ou ainda pior ainda abaixo de
0,18 a chance de ser câncer aumenta
bastante tá mas da não quer dizer que é
100% liberado de ter câncer se a relação
foi acima de 0,20 tá o PC to de uso é
esse 0,20 abaixo 0,20 o risco de câncer
é
maior Carlos há alguns anos alguns
médicos funcionais diziam que é muito
difícil utilizar absorver ômega-3 de
cereais
vegetais ultimamente disse que é inútil
ingerir farinha de cereais para absorver
omega3 pois estará tud oxidado
recomenda-se agora moer os grãos
sementes em gerir imediatamente para
evitar a
oxidação considerando que exame relação
ômega-3 ômega-6 no corpo é pouco usado
não tenho como saber da real absorção de
ômega-3 de cereais moídos e ingeridos
imediatamente nem aça por exemplo Qual
sua avaliação desse
assunto consegue se
absolver então é um assunto que não tá
totalmente definido ainda eu acho que
você puder eh moer na hora que você for
utilizar a linhaça é melhor tá mas
lembre-se que tem ômega-3 também em ovos
caipiras tem omega-3 também em carne que
come predominante descul não carne o
gado né a carne do Gado que come
predominantemente grama
então que que eu recomendo tá não fica
tão B secado com essa questão da linhaça
usa linhaça do jeito que você consegue
usar se você não consegue moer na hora
eh aceitável usar linhaça de outra forma
e complementa esse omega-3 com óleo de
peixe eu eu tomo Du pelo menos duas
cápsulas de ômega-3 por dia e
complementa com ovos caipiras que eu
como todos os dias tá essa que é a minha
visão mais prática possível tá sem ficar
eh eh Desculpa falar isso punhetando
muito tá Desculpe o temo feio pessoas
desculpe
aí o que acontece tem alguns
profissionais eh que gostam de complicar
para dizer que ele é o fodão que ele
sabe bastante e que ele lê os artigos e
tem que ser do jeito dele senão não
funciona tá gente a gente tem que fazer
do jeito que dá entendeu é muito melhor
fazer meia boca não fazer
nada certo então não ficam Não fiquem
assim paralisados por essas questões não
tá e desculpe os palavrões aí
ã próxima pergunta Marilda Na
ressonância prostática de risco pirad
que valor já é considerado o risco de
câncer prostático depende tá a maioria
dos urologistas consideram pirads 3 já
problemático eu considero pirads 4 e
pirads 5
tá César Venâncio eh para se elevar os
níveis de iG
fpp3 É o Jef é o é o insulin grow like
insulin like Grow Factory BP binding
Protein 3 tá somente um sono reparador
seria suficiente ou Há algum suplemento
direcionado para
isso então o igf não o igf pp3 tá o igf
ele aumenta quando você tem um boa noite
sono quando você come proteínas de alto
valor biológico o e Protein por exemplo
aumenta o
igf e a musculação também aumenta o GF
tá então aminoácidos essenciais o
Protein e fontes proteínas de alto valor
biológico aumenta o
igf próxima
pergunta altas doses de B1 no sangue
podem levar a aumento de probabilidade
de câncer não não aumenta a
probabilidade de câncer porque tem
alguns cânceres que aumenta b então é o
contrário tá Ah então B12 é no sangue
geralmente é muito intol não intoxica
porque é uma vitamina hidrossolúvel só
que você tá jogando dinheiro fora então
se sua vitamina B12 passou de 1500 e
diminui a suplementação de B12 tá porque
não que vai fazer mal mas tá jogando
dinheiro
fora um paciente do sexo masculino por
volta dos 50 anos faz uso de Sereno
repens ou sal palmeto que é mesma coisa
regularmente com dos de 160 mg Mas pode
apresentar ja vadores de baixo DT no
sangue geralmente não é a causa o o sal
pom medo tá há alguma referência para
saber se o tratamento está sendo eficaz
para qu de
cabelo referência saber é ver que o
cabelo tá melhorando né Não entendi não
sei se eu entendi bem essa sua pergunta
aqui você vai saber se tá sendo eficaz
vendo se o cabelo tá tá crescendo
novamente né Tira uma foto antes e uma
foto
depois se você ti tiver ao assistindo ao
vivo tá de repente pode tentar
esclarecer melhor isso eu não sei se eu
entendi bem a sua sua
dúvida
eh macuto moral 72 4 então de 15 em
exame coletado de um homem pode enicar
problema em Qual órgão esse marcador ele
não é específico tá ele ele geralmente
pode indicar câncer de pâncreas mas ele
é Aumenta também em câncer de ovário e
também outras situações el aumenta
tá pelo pouco que eu pesquisei mostra
possibilidade de estômago mas também
colo retal pâncreas e até pulmão poderia
dar uma explicação primeiro eu não gosto
de usar esses marcadores porque esses
marcadores são para acompanhamento de
paciente já Tratado de câncer não é para
diagnosticar câncer tá mas se a pessoa
tiver uma macad aumentado tem que
investigar se não tem aí algum câncer
Inicial nesses órgãos aí mas eu não
gosto de usar esse marcadores para
tentar fazer diagnóstico de câncer
porque tá muito falso
positivo então eu não peço isso tá
porque quando você pede dar positivo o
paciente fica extremamente estressado e
na maioria das vezes não é
câncer ru Elita o Fit terápico slip da
naal pode ser usado de modo contínuo
preciso ver o que que tem nesse produto
tá eu não uso
ele vou olhar agora
aqui
tá ele tem pera
aí consegui ampliar suficientemente aqui
o o rótulo para
ler É parece que é só melatonina isso
aqui não tem extrat de
Valeriana aí tem
maracujá e
gaba Sim pode ser usado continuamente
sim
viu esse local que eu tô vendo aqui não
tá muito bom de ver não deixa eu olhar
em outra só para ter
certeza pera aí deixa eu entrar no site
oficial daf
é extrato de
Valeriana tem
lúpulo tem o Passion flower que é o
maracujá e o Gaba não pode ser usado
contínuo sim sem
problemas
ã existe um tratamento que não seja
cortic para dermatite atópica de
nascença a criança tem 3
anos tem que investigar a causa dessa
dermatite e afastar a criança do que tá
provocando essa dermatite tá você pode
usar probióticos para ajudar você pode
usar quercetina que é um antialérgico
natural usar agentes antiinflamatórios
né Por exemplo unha de gato tem alguns
fpos que ajudam né mas uma criança
pequena assim a melhor coisa é
investigar a causa e afastar a criança
disso
daí da causa dati atópica suplementos
que ajudam estão pode causar algum
problema no pâncreas ou algum outro
órgão que o SAC não eh naturopata
recomendou um suplemento com objetivo de
limpar o fígado canadian bits mas fico
com receio quando tomo em jejum apenas
Como suporte do fígado pois na embalagem
distônico
digestivo Mas por que tem que tomar em
[Música]
jejum não tome jejum então ué É até
melhor que você tome isso aí junto com
alimento porque esses biters né que é o
cachorro de leão eles ajudam na digestão
tá não tem razão se tomar em jejum não
tá
di sacaram bulard ajuda no tratamento
apenas da cândida ou infecção fúngica em
geral infecção fica em geral
ajuda vamos ver os comentários
é seguro tomar ivet por 30 dias com
protocolo antiparasitário por Zoologia
de acordo com a bula eu acho que sim
Miria a própria lucier tem passado o uso
de Ivete por se meses direto tá eu não
tenho coragem de fazer isso mas ela tem
feito mais um mês eu posso dizer que é
seguro sim
certo pessoal temos mais dúvidas ao
vivo colher uma comer uma colher de sopa
de pem apícola desidratado todo dia vai
gerar excesso de frutose no
fígado não não vai
não sim reduz as estamin sim
Eliseu sim existe o tudo com o pólen do
trigo para redução da próstata ele ajuda
sim comer castanha de baru cru é ruim
paraa saúde desconheço isso
Eliseu usar roupas de poliester diminui
a testosteron por causa dos
xenoestrógenos
pode acontecer isso sim
tá sim a a resposta é sim Eliseu
eh não hipogonadismo Mas podem causar
eh entupimento do receptor de
testosterona que causa redução do efeito
da testosterona no
organismo Qual é a quantidade ideal de
saponinas que o tribulus deve
ter de cabeça agora não sei mas isso não
é difícil
de de descobrir tá se isso para você é
importante eu vejo para você isso agora
aqui a zeólita pode prevenir ess
notificações apresentadas no seu vídeo
Qual o vídeo
miram mas de modo geral a zeola sim pode
prevenir intoxicações
gostaria de saber se além do aspecto
visual se no exame de sangue no caso DHT
ele apresenta alguma baixa de valor em
relação aos valores anteriores ele vai
baixar assim um pouco o DHT mas não vai
baixar muito não viu
César Nossa não é 650 MG até errada essa
dose que colocou aí é muito grande essa
dose a pessoa até morre não é 650 milig
de zinco não tá isso vai intoxicar a
pessoa no máximo 50 mg por dia
alzu não faça isso você vai se
intoxicar tem um pouquinho de caloria no
Aloe Vera Eliseu vai quebrar sim o jejum
Tá mas vai quebrar pouco mas vai
quebrar é mais por conta da liberação do
receptor eh por conta da regulação do
cortisol cortisol iní o receptor de
testosterona quando tá em
excesso não não tem essa necessidade
você fica secado com o tempo de
cozimento do ovo não tá
eh eu eu cozinhar até ele ficar duro
mesmo tá não senão você pode cor ISO de
alguma intoxicação eu não acho que vale
a pena ficar secado deixar o ovo quase
cru só porque ele vai perder um pouco de
nutriente
cozimento é que tem mais de um vídeo
sobre isso miram por isso que eu tô
perguntando para
você curso de testosteron para leigos
vou pensar no assunto
elizu mas o curso de prosta tá liberado
para quem quiser comprar mas ele é um
curso mais técnico
tá não é impossível você tem que comer
uma quantidade muito grande de alimentos
sem sem
dúvida sim confere
Eliseu não Eliseu é exagero isso a
vitamina D não resolve todos os
problemas do mundo não
Não não é verdade isso não
elizu não não o na vai aumentar muito
mais a gruta do que a vitamina
D então a história que o l Ribeiro conta
que deriva do livro do doutor stepen
Sinatra é que somente o LDL de partícula
pequena e densa
seria o problema tá porque essa
partícula que oxida essa que formação
dos cardiologistas metabólicos Estados
Unidos sim eu comentei isso no artigo né
a vitamina D pode ajudar a regular a
pressão arterial e prevenir a
hipertensão sim de nada
milia tá Mas respondendo a dúvida do
Eliseu que tá preocupado com o nível de
toninas do tribos terrestres tá eh tal a
maioria dos estudos utiliza dos entre 20
a
45% de saponinas tá então entre 20 e
45% saponinas não sal palmeto
tá então tá respondido aí a pergunta do
Eliseu
de nada
eles menor do que 06 viu César tá menor
que 06
sim é melhor esperar 3 horas depois do
jantar pelo menos para para dormir é
verdade
isso não não posso dar ao Luxo de dormir
al você pode dar ao Luxo Mas vai ter
algum comprometimento tá
bem vamos ficar até às 8 horas da noite
tá para dar pelo menos 45 minutos de
Live
Então tá ruim tá se essa relação tá um
tá ruim precisa então rever a sua
alimentação fazer atividade física e
talvez entrar com medicamento para
baixar o a
b Ok o que que pode usar doses baixas de
statina com com enzima queed ex
nicotinato dinosol berberina extrato de
Bergamota tocot trenois
ômega3 são todas substâncias que podem
ajudar a melhorar essa relação aí
OK lembrando pessoal tudo fica gravado
vocês podem rever quantas vezes quiser
pode Pô o vídeo para correr mais lento
mais rápido do jeito que vocês quiserem
não sei se vocês conhecem ess recursos
que tem no YouTube de você acelerar ou
retardar a velocidade da da fala de nada
César
bem hoje de manhã eu fiz a minha
musculação fiz
costas e agora à noite eu vou fazer meu
aeróbico que não deu tempo de fazer de
manhã então saindo daqui da Live vou
passar em casa vou me trocar e se a
minha mulher não fizer chantagem
emocional como ela fez ontem eu vou para
a academia à noite fazer o aeróbico que
eu não sei porque que ela acha que à
noite as coisas são mais perigosas quer
dizer até É né mas deixar de fazer as
coisas porque talvez acontece alguma
coisa você pensa que é só vocês que tem
mulher ciumenta vocês homens aí que
estão assistindo
não é só vocês
não a minha é bastante
ciumenta mas eu não pego nem gripe na
academia ninguém olha para mim na
academia ninguém sabe que sou Doutor do
YouTube lá eu sou um ilustre
desconhecido
entendeu o pessoal me olha lá só acha
que eu sou um coroa tá malhando lá não
sabe nem quem quem eu sou entendeu
ai
ai bem p pess Acho que acabaram as
dúvidas
né não não dou motivo não eu não dou
motivo não ai ai ai eu não dou motivo
não aliás mesmo que você desse motivo
meu minha moral para baixo na academia
lá viu ninguém olha para mim lá não viu
negócio tá tá
feio D Aninha cuidando seu tesouro
boa Ai cara tem que tem que brincar um
pouco né o pessoal reclama muito que eu
sou muito sério né sério demais D al é
muito
sério não Adriana eu não dou motivo não
eu achei engraçado só não dou motivo
nenhum não até porque Nossa Senhora acho
que a última coisa que eu quero hoje é
confusão com a minha mulher pelo amor de
Deus última coisa que eu quero confusão
é 5 minutos de prazer e 3 anos de
inferno não tem sentido né a conta não
fecha mesmo que eu cometesse essa
impropriedade não não faria sentido eu
pular cerca entendeu seria seria tão
ruim a consequência
que não a conta não fecha tá pessoal
Desculpa aí Pelas brincadeiras pelas Bob
mas não dar um pouquinho de risada
também eu acho que eu preciso realmente
a minha filha fala que eu sou muito
sério eu
preciso falar besteira de vez em quando
Obrigado
Eliane Obrigado a todos aí um grande
abraço para vocês até a semana que vem é
casal 20 tem razão